mientras que bailén está de visita en el
medio oriente hay malas noticias
económicas en casa la inflación vuelve a
registrar otro récord de en junio los
precios de los productos y los servicios
básicos subieron un 9,1 por ciento en
eeuu en comparación con el mismo mes del
año anterior una cifra alarmante
teniendo en cuenta que en mayo la
inflación era del 86 %
el alza en los precios de la gasolina la
subida precipitada al en alquiler y los
altos precios de la comida catapultaron
la inflación los más afectados han sido
y seguirán siendo la clase media y las
minorías hispanas y afroamericanas que
destinan la mayoría de sus recursos a la
renta el transporte y la comida según
economistas la situación llevar a que la
reserva federal tenga que subir más
rápido sus tasas de interés para tratar
de controlar la inflación al atraer el
dinero circulante que está calentando la
economía hecho que podría llevar a una
recesión económica el próximo año como
lo dicen algunos analistas porque esto
llevaría a que el costo de endeudamiento
sea alto y termine afectando la
inversión y la producción en eeuu